so this is an M 65 anarchy jacket it was
once available at Barney's disappeared
described as a military inspired cloak
it only goes for and I stress only three
hundred and seventy-five dollars
allegedly aping the spirit of Anti Fog
it costs more than your average suit the
symbol of evil greedy capitalism so this
jacket is military inspired so I guess
now it's good to be inspired by the
military if it's only fashion and
fascist based of course god forbid
you're actually inspired by actual
elements of military service patriotism
selflessness bravery no instead be
inspired to dress like someone who
actually hates such traits and prefers
to mock any service to one's country the
jacket maker out the industry industries
also supplies the US military they claim
this jacket encompasses expressions on
individuality yes how individualistic
covering yourself in phony slogans and
meaningless symbols why not just slap
bumper stickers across your face you
don't know my goodness so in the most
expensive city in the nation Manhattan
within the priciest or you could outfit
the trust-fund revolutionary the
champion of the downtrodden hater of the
man enemy combatant a big business greed
and patriarchy you can wear his hipster
jacket at brunch to parade as
progressive finalities while dripping
cage-free eggs down the front of his
freshly Aaron chase dirt all for 400
bucks that's a bargain for us too now we
can spot the loser a mile away
Kimberly yeah see this coming at me let
me tell you they better go in the other
direction yes it would a man Bundy with
this - I would hope so the man but or
even the high top man - up here it's got
the dork knob I believe I've heard the
dork now I think this is way too
expensive it'd be better if it was
something that was like look at it 55
bucks that I don't even know probably
know where but it is just in the
military you earn a jacket like that
yeah thing it just seems like you're
trying too hard
you want to break windows because you
don't really want to have to go out and
do it you got the wrong by the way
protests at Berkeley yes but no one
hears it caught it on the back it has an
anarchy symbol and on the front and our
key means chaos how why can't we just
steal this jacket aren't you encouraging
fad like white why do I have to pay for
it why can't I just break the window and
steal the jacket good so I'm just gonna
be a cranky old man cuz I think the
jackets ridiculous but it's ridiculous
be this jack has been around since I was
a kid basically true it's people who
want to say I'm hip I'm different I'm
anti-establishment I'm a hipster except
but I mean it's a ridiculous jacket I
mean to me when I walk down the street
and I see these people with pants that
are torn yeah and I know they think and
I bet they pay a lot of money right for
these torn pants right but it's the
fashion look right you know Jesse I
called to see if they had one that had
the collar up for you you said about
cage free eggs I like cage free they
taste better if you read the little bird
in the Barneys catalog it says looking
good while you stab a police horse they
also got the color wrong if you watch
Antipa they're all wearing black right
why are the fashion person yeah I
respect though Barney's for trying to
capitalize off people who hate
capitalism Tina we went to find this it
was out there this weekend when they
were having the anti-shah protests they
claim it's not an anti fraud jacket
expired but we can't find it it's no
longer at Barney's and we called the
company Sean called the company and they
they refused to acknowledge what where
this jacket when they're hidden
somewhere in the showroom they're gonna
be on eBay yeah interesting I saw it I
came across a couple of articles Oh
excellent work about how politics was
the biggest trend at New York Fashion
Week Wow 17 so if I mean this is
basically I guess Barney's is just
following on yes what that's what people
want that's true nobody wants people had
some about Trump wearing you know and
gotta be rich and they had the t-shirts
nevertheless she persisted for like $300
well my friend Ann has that bag too yeah
a lot of women who are that nasty woman
t-shirt is that so I mean they're just
making money off of politics but you
know I just think it's self-expression
it's just so it's like a it's like a
comedy that
rich are buying these crazy right you
don't know if you can't afford this
you're not an Tifa yeah I don't cover
this years a decades ago correct that's
exactly right
all right one